donc là laurent vous avez pris
possession donc d'une maison que vous
avez acheté 140000 euros on avait vu que
sur l'acte de vente figuraient que la
maison était occupée sans titre voilà
vous prenez possession de cette maison
on s'aperçoit donc que la famille qui
s'en va est à lui et c'est là vous
faites des travaux on s'aperçoit que
vous êtes mis en examen moi j'ai une
question directe à vous poser d'après
nos informations effectivement il n'ya
pas que ça d'après nos informations vous
avez déjà fait de la prison florent est
ce que c'est vrai alors oui parce qu'il
voudra bien sûr de sûr j'espère qu'il
dira la vérité mais avait dit la vérité
j'ai été plusieurs fois en présence et
alors mais c'est vrai on a le droit de
purger sa peine et d'avoir fédéré par le
rejet par le roi donc j'ai parents
d'acheter une maison c'est ça c'est sûr
que c'est surtout que ces cétacés tam
accompagne la maison
entièrement à ma compagne aurait t on la
maison était achetée par votre compagne
oui oui entièrement moi j'ai pas mis un
euro dans la maison qu'est-ce que ça à
voir avec le trafic de stupéfiants
qu'est-ce que ça à voir on dévoilement
casier on dévoile tout je vois pas trop
alors laurent on a juste pour savoir
vous avez et iront en prison pourquoi
progrès étaient auparavant oui pour des
délits routiers délit routier italien
état d'ivresse là d'accord ouais comme
un temps ma plus grosse peine de prison
sept mois cette mort pourquoi délits
routiers ouais c'est quoi de conduite en
état d'ivresse et en état d'ivresse
d'accord donc sept mois de prison quand
on parle de trafic de stupéfiants c'est
vrai c'est aussi vous êtes ont mis en
examen pour ça on est mersin en examen
on est dans notre trafic de stupéfiants
d'accord mais quand on dit trafic de
foot et non c'est juste bout c'est aussi
votre autre compagne ma compagne elle
est liée à la faire juste parce que
juste parce qu'elle voyait ce qui se
passait finalement à la maison mais elle
a rien à voir d'ailleurs à la paf et un
jour de prison d'accord voilà moi j'ai
moi j'étais en prison pour cette affaire
rafik de stupéfiants vous avez déjà et
ont prises en exaltant pour détention
illicite d'armes de catégorie b et c
était quoi commun un fusil de chasse et
et un poing américain d'accord et
participation à une association de
malfaiteurs en vue de la préparation
d'un des listes est quoi c'est ça c'est
tout le préfère les stupéfiants l
affaire de stupéfiants d'accord c'est
même maillot c'est vrai que c'est sorti
à la radio ces voix là et sur les
réseaux
puis poser des questions
mais on s'aperçoit au fil d'un jeu que
le passé votre client et et son présent
et quand même compliqué alors certes ça
n'a rien à voir avec l'achat moi j mais
quand on connaît les conditions de
l'achat a vu son passé de délinquant ça
pose des questions on apprenait question
est-ce que l'achat est clair mais je
vais trouver moi lâche éric et déjà
juste je voudrais prendre une minute
pour pour rétablir quelques vérités
parce que il ya une thèse officielle
maintenant qui est de dire dans les
médias depuis deux jours je regarde même
ici d'ailleurs de dire voilà en fait la
thèse officielle c'est laurent a menti
aux médias parce qu'il savait que la
maison est occupée par une famille et
qu'il a acheté pour ça les maisons moins
cher c'est la thèse que tout le monde
partage c'est ce qu'on entend partout
bien sûr même sauf que c'est pas c'est
pas ça du tout on est venu lundi et je
le répéte est aujourd'hui encore une
fois laurent il n'a pas menti aux médias
dans la mesure où il ne savait pas que
c'était une famille installée dans la
maison avec chirurgie changé avec
abonnement edf y avait qu un fauteuil de
propriété il pensait et c'est ce qu'il
dit et c'est la vérité que c'était
squatter occasionnellement par une
personne de temps en temps avec 1 1
d'ailleurs un matelas ça change tout
parce que il s'est dit je vais rentrer
dans les maisons après l'achat et on va
verrouiller on va mettre des serrures on
va telle menace et on sera tranquille au
premier trimestre par dont la rente et
non
pas ce que vous dites c'est que le
notaire dit dans le parisien quand ils
sont partis c'est même la première fois
que je fais une signature où les gens
passent sans les clés oui alors si par
sans les clés c'est pas un truc
occasions alors c'est qu'il ya des gens
qu'on est clé de la mais n'ont pas
forcément que d'ailleurs lui a dit
d'édifier notaire et peut-être qu il ya
quelqu un de mes 6 ans d'histoire
j'ai pas les clés
n'ont pas les clés
monsieur lacroix les 30 secondes et j'ai
terminé le tour down nick leddy voilà
l'histoire des clés il n'a pas eu la clé
le jour de la vente d'ailleurs on voit
une vidéo où la voix des gens mais ne le
dit pas continuer clé quelques jours
après pourquoi je dis ça parce que j'ai
eu sur les réseaux sociaux et même page
il en parlait autrefois en fait on a on
a lu on a dit que ce trousseau de clés
qui l'a ramenée qui revient avec ce soir
c'est un trousseau qui est totalement
bidon qu'il n'a jamais eu les clés les
clés c'est lui qui la jugent entre les
mains et lui qu'on a dit ça ce sont les
clés de
ce son et que de la maison et d'ailleurs
il ya un petit nom un petit porte-clefs
qui est gravé au nom du vendeur ya le
nom du vendeur c'est un détail mais tout
ça pour dire que s'il ya plein de choses
qui sont d'ici qui sont fausses
deuxièmement
ce sont les clés la juge ordonne c'est
le premier jeu clé laurent l'a reconnu
mais même là il a un jeu technique qui
sont les clients qu'il a bien eu un jeu
que j'attends d'eux n'est pas le jour de
ses natures et je voudrais juste
préciser à sion la chad l'achat 140000
euros alors on dit attendez juste deux
minutes pour revenir sur les quais frère
il ya quand même important
d'écouter alors on fait normalement fin
plan syrie voilà quand on réalise
l'émission enfin plans serrés sur les
cli voilà donc c'est très simple quand
il fait réaliser l'émission c'est non
c'est pas un plan serré ça sert pour
l'américain voilà ça c'est un plan serré
sur les clés voilà merci je vais aussi
m'occuper de la réalisation de
l'émission c'est aussi simple que ça va
normalement quand on fait une vanne faut
vraiment volaille sur le banc fait une
vanne sur les clés les mots clés les
clés sont la voilà la paire à ses
admirateurs ça c'est clair d'accord ça
ces écrans voilà merci en régie oui bon
je termine
deuxième précision ce qui ont ce qu'on
répète tout le temps c'est qu'en fait il
a acheté la maison bien moins cher que
le prix du marché cent quarante mille
euros le 240000 euros il a fait une
super affaire et c'est moins cher du
prix de marché moi je dis non il n'a pas
du tout acheter la maison moins cher que
le prix du marché on l'a dit on le
répète c'est une maison en fait quand on
n'est pas comme salaire minable mais de
n'en est rien on sait tous qu'on a tous
eu des travaux dans la vie lorsqu'on
fait venir à neuf chez par un
entrepreneur juste si on fait le sol la
plomberie une salle de bal et c'est vers
là pour 50000 là il ya au moins cent
mille euros de travaux
vous répondez oui messieurs c'est
vraiment intéressant dès
jeudi les clés non face à la question et
si on sait combien on dit si beau
coupable c'est ça la question il avait
sélectionné ici parfois il ya là qui le
traite comme un coupable oui donc c'est
ça qu'on vous pose la question où le
pose ici chez vous juste laurent il
paraît que tu dis est maintenant en
enfer parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
viennent dans ta maison tu te reconnais
ce qui c'est c'est une pas des pauvres
bah ouais ouais tout tout le monde bien
bon allez les gens dans l'ensemble sont
plutôt avec moi mais il ya quelques
quelques personnes effectivement qui
parce qu'ils sont pas qu'ils sont pas
contentes après voilà mais moi je trouve
ça quand même un peu dommage de vous
l'avouerez quoi vous remets mon casier
judiciaire non non vous retenez qu'il
avance à la basse et un problème de
squats et c'est un problème de squats
faut régler les problèmes de squats on
est parti complètement sur autre chose
il ya plein de gens dans mon cas là il
faut les régler ses problèmes de squats
on parle carrément d'autres choses
s'améliorent le problème c'est que plus
on avance dans cette histoire plus tout
est confus moi moi je dis plus confus
confus qu'on laisse à ma juste final je
dis pas que vous êtes victime ou
coupable il plus ça avance plus c'est
confus et malheureusement ça va
desservir aux prochaines victimes de ce
quad parce que maintenant ça sera plus
audible il aura pour toujours un soupçon
sur les conditions et alors qu'il ya une
urgence est réglée changer la loi parce
que la loi est mais là on construit
portables et donc contraire j'ai prouvé
j'éprouve et là tout le monde quand 24
48 heures on peut les régler les
problèmes à l'excès l'humain voilà j'ai
trouvé ça tout le monde voit pas
pourquoi les études datant des années
est ce que vous n'avez pas tout dit vous
savez pas dit toute la bbc bon moins bon
au moins ça aurait servi à ça et vous
avez du pénal avait dû
et c'est en même temps la barbe laissez
le parler et quand on vous dit que vous
avez duper les gens vous répéter dans
les coins bah non je me suis servi des
médias je me suis bien le voir mais de
toute façon en médiatisant la faire vous
saviez que peut être potentiellement ça
allait sortir d'un risque que vous
preniez mon casier judiciaire du stop ça
me dérange pas du tout la preuve je
viens ici aujourd'hui vous êtes terrain
d'une arythmie en examen encore oui je
suis mis en examen va être jugé je pense
en fin d'année où vous avez fait 8 mois
de placard non je fais six mois et demi
je pense que ce soit discipliné d'accord
au bout c'est fini mais voilà si vous
achetez la maison à quel moment par
rapport à votre incarcération jeu sort
le 9 mai je l'achète le 19 mai je
l'achète mcluhan la chef qui devra pas
pour ce qu'ils savent faire de calculs
moi je vais vous dire moi je vais je
vais je vais donner un peu mon avis là
dessus
bien sûr on a cette histoire on sait pas
trop s'il savait s'ils savaient pas et
c'est à moi juste ceux qui se servent du
casier judiciaire viola ce quelqu'un
pour dire s'il a un casier judiciaire
c'est qu'il est coupable ça c'est
insupportable
il ya plein de gens qui sont en prison
qui ont purgé leur peine et qui ont
envie voilà de rebondir dans la vie et
qui ont envie d'avoir une vie normale
donc ça tous ceux qui ont fait ça et
pour moi et on l'a repris ici même le
casier judiciaire je vous dis pour moi
ça c'est dégueulasse non mais je vous
dis c'est dégueulasse parce que c'est
c'est on a on a tous le droit de faire
des erreurs il a purgé sa peine il a
fait 8 mois de de kkr donc voilà
aujourd'hui c'est pas parce qu'il a fait
huit mois le placard que c'est lui qui
est devenu non coupable on a envie de
savoir la vérité sur cette affaire c'est
tout voilà mais c'est vrai que je
voulais vu même ici voilà il a beaucoup
dont gilles qui disait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant les témoins
oui c'est là
c'est laurent moi je vous pose la
question directement est-ce que les 140
mille euros c'est l'argent de la drogue
dans sa femme
qui est une très bonne question parce
que la seule circuler j'ai aussi entendu
qu'il a vu une valise avec 140 mille
euros en espèces et c'est l'argent de la
drogue bien sûr alors sur ça que j'ai
demandé de venir avec des documents en
fait il a acheté la maison 140000 euros
et la fin crédit auprès d'une grande
banque française aurait cessé d'acheter
non enfin ça oui c'est vrai ils sont ici
c'est normal non et sont pas mariés bon
on comptait peut-être faire un enfant
voilà on comptait sur la maison pour
avancer un petit peu dans la vie mais là
on en est maintenant vous n'avez jamais
consommé vous attendez la maison pour
faire passer ça valait le citepa marina
mais alors c'est sa femme qui l'a
achetée maintenant c'est un couple c'est
un pape qui l'a achetée et il ya crédit
qui a été fait de 140000 euros donc 100%
à crédit la seule somme qu'ils ont misé
ce sont ces l'apport ya 15000 euros sont
les frais de notaire qui sont pas pris
en charge et les frais notaire il
n'avait même pas les 4000 euros ils ont
fait le tour de la famille on leur a
prêtés et de jeunes mais j'ai demandé
pour être complet parce que je n'ai pas
envie de dire des bêtises non plus donc
il est venu avec son crédit il est même
venu avec une lettre de la banque qui
atteste l'origine des fonds je sais que
cyril veut l'avoir dont je les prépare
et donc il ya vraiment nos problèmes là
dessus faut savoir qu'ils travaillent
pas sa compagne il ya une autour de 2000
euros c'est pas des gens riches on pense
qu'il a fait une super affaire qui va
s'en mettre plein les poches il va voir
5000 euros travaux donc il va revenir au
prix du marché et sont d'été pendant 25
ans +1 près de 50000 euros pour les
travaux cinquante mille euros pour
commencer les travaux donc et au moins
5000 euros de travaux et ils sont
endettés pendant 25 ans donc l argent de
la drogue que ça ce sont des délires
qu'on entend plus quelques jours fériés
je suis passé à autre chose
[ __ ] on sait qu'une antenne
patrimoniale ce qui a marqué cette
saison
ah bon
non non non ça c'est le non non non ça
c'est la personne et la montée en élite
sûrs aujourd'hui trois côtés au delà
grille je n'ai jamais fait de près parce
que je ne peux pas faire des examens de
sang donc forcément je ne fais jamais
fait si je ne fais jamais d'examen temps
je ne peux pas d'étaler un emprunt je
déteste les piqûres ninon le bras ni
dans le cul voilà on joue dur ça c'est
une histoire vraie et voilà c'est une
info que je voudrais je te dis voilà je
tu as fait une taille est un fameux
scénariste le prêt je sais pas attendez
attendez pas pour contrôler la prise de
sang la prise de sang les gens qui
achètent des maisons à 200 250 milles
les assurances ç'a passé un certain
seuil et ils demandent des prises de
sang des examens mais sans pousser pop
c'est bien et c'est ça oui ou possible
politique évidemment victime c'est
insupportable sur ce plateau y en a qui
se croit dans un tribunal comme gilles
verdez ils pensent que c'est à eux de
dire si monsieur telle chose alors c'est
à la justice
évidemment laurent et est innocent c'est
pas parce qu'il a été mis en examen pour
des affaires qui n'ont rien à voir qui
doit être coupable surtout équidés
fautif surtout il est innocent et je
trouve ça pas très clean de la part des
médias on a l'impression que parce
qu'ils seront là on la reprise mais oui
mais on a besoin que parce qu'ils se
sont faits entre guillemets berner ses
seins se venge en sortant des
informations qui n'ont rien à voir pour
influencer l'opinion contre laurent et
moi j'étais large de la côte est de
booster avec votre femme et vous avez
dit on a acheté une maison à gaza on
était tous contents d'y aller et au
moment de mettre la clé il y avait des
gens des gens ben on va nous dire la
vérité au moins justes il y avait des
squatteurs on le savait quand on l'a
acheté peut-être des squatteurs
occasionnels c'est tous ces
gestionnaires sont jacques
j'étais là ces
avait peut-être des jeunes de temps en
temps qui viennent squatter 700 dont
j'étais là on était tous contents
d'aller rouler dans la maison et un
moment d'y aller on a vu que j'avais
déjà on sait pas entendu le fameux show
c'est ce qui fait qu'on a posté des
primes pour déconner va demander lui
[Musique]
j'ai un pont du 15 fois les squatteurs
occasionnels voilà j'ai acheté la maison
en tant que tel c'est tout bardon
peut-être après ça après tout un tout un
bazar centrale a demandé et géraldine
avait raison il ya deux jours dit mais
pourquoi pendant sept mois faisait pas
partie vérifièrent est pas là bas il n'a
pas voulu en parler parce qu il est
possible d bah oui je vais dire les gars
donc les temps pedro n'a pas pu savoir
que pendant ces sept mois il ya
quelqu'un de lambres ah bah non il
obligé de raconter sa vie ce matin
j'écoute la radio élites urbaines oui il
a vu la laver la maison sept mois avant
trois-quatre fois c'est évident après il
a signé quand il est sorti sa femme a
signé avec lui et dont il me l'a pas vu
entre temps donc les temps présents
en suisse est alors donc avoir du tout
non sa femme est le papa et le barbecue
c'est un petit peu à skis à d'années
alors dit nous pour toi n'est coupable
non alors moi et pour moi yeux je sais
pas s'il est coupable il est responsable
c'est des responsables en fait c'est
vous qui avait médiatisé la faire on
vous a pas forcé vous en avez profité
puisque vous êtes dans cette maison vous
n'auriez on est d'accord vous n'auriez
pas été dans cette maison aujourd'hui si
vous n'avez pas méditer donc ça vous en
avez profité tant mieux pour vous donc
évidemment maintenant n'allez quand même
pas essayé nous faire pleurer parce que
votre casier judiciaire a été mais
plutôt moins ça me dérange j'ai quand
même on a comme nom de famille ma
compagne il ya peut-être médiatisation
n'était peut-être pas au courant chaud
ces deux dans son staff sont sympa cool
que moi sinon je serais pas venu
m'expliquer maintenant je serai caché
limites mais moi personnellement ça me
dérange pas je trouve qu'en fait à la
limite ça ne cherchent leur équipe
certes ce casier judiciaire donc j'ai
dis pas ça mais simplement et on le voit
là je n'ai pas envie de pleurer quand
vous me dites que on a dévoilé votre
casier judiciaire c'est vous qui vous
êtes médiatiser tout seul
un squat est pas pour être pas peur
d'autres choses voilà c'est pas c'est
pas normal de venir raconter sa vie vous
pensez que c'est ses proches sa famille
je crois c'est ma famille n'était pas au
courant les voisins son futur employeur
et travail qui cherchent un emploi
qu'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant
aujourd'hui partout c'était en
appréciant c'est jacques mesrine
vas-y la notoriété qui veut être acteur
et qui après râle parce que les gens
leur demandent
avec un filet mais je le sais delphine
capelle delphine banane on
en tire si il était venu en disant
bonjour je m'appelle laurent chaque
année judiciaire j'ai un problème avec
ma maison personne ne l'aurait écouté
donc effectivement il n'a pas dit qu'il
avait un casier judiciaire parce que ça
ne servait en rien aux dépens problème
de ce qu'on est en train d'oublier
totalement bon alors moi je suis pas
d'accord avec tout ce que vous avez fait
apparemment vous avez purgé votre peine
mais moi j'ai envie de vous prendre en
porte parole de tous ces gens qui
subissent la loi qui est cette loi qui
est mal font subtiliser piécourt les
squatteurs et contre les propriétaires
sauf moi j'ai pas envie de vous accablez
parce que vous êtes allé en prison vous
avez réglé votre truc j'ai envie qu'on
écoute le fond du problème est que vous
serviez et que ce que vous avez vécu
serve aux autres il faut changer la loi
pour savoir qu'il faut retenir c'est que
la loi il ya à la changer justement en
janvier 2021 maintenant c'est beaucoup
plus simple pour les propriétaires qui
fait déposer une plate ont fait
constater le squat on vient dire que les
propriétaires et on va voir le procureur
qui peut les faire partir c'est que son
initiative le problème c'est que souvent
ça fonctionne pas là que ce qui s'est
passé gerdemann ans lui a passé un coup
de fil elle procure ans il l'a fait mais
normalement c'est pas le sénateur gérald
darmanin en vue du préfet non plus de
quelqu'un personnel à voile et
d'éducateurs non plus son parti ils ont
interrogé serait relogé par la ville il
aura été relogés par le maire dans un
sens c'est vrai agressé le jour de tes
une enquête en cours je sais pas moi moi
pour moi je me suis dit au début c'est
un coup monté et apparemment les voisins
ont vraiment entendu du bruit
et après changements sans que j'en sais
pas plus il sort de prison mais pas
longtemps quand on dit est ce que c est
ce que tu n'es pas à mêler à l'agression
on se doute bien que sortant de prison
il va pas organiser une agression qui
lui servira à rien ça aussi c'est des
fantasmes qu'on a pu qu'on a pu voir là
dessus il a aucune raison d'expliquer
aux gens du parisien la première fois
qu'il est qu'il a un casier judiciaire
on revient pas il postule pas pas dans
la police ou pour combi de france où il
faut avoir un casier judiciaire mais un
concours miss mais c'est vrai ça n'a
rien à voir il a parlé d'un squat et
vire pas parler il veut se résorbera
police dont il aucune raison de raconter
tout ça donc il n'a pas dit mais il est
pas coupable de pas l'avoir dit parce
qu'on l'a pas demandé puis l'a pas le
dire ils voulaient me remettrai à
lui-même y être ma voix mais vous l'avez
dit m ben on en a pas parlé honnêtement
d'un danger dit mcnabb a tout du temps
que c'est vrai que c'est pas un garçon
qui est hyper loquace voilà comme ça
donc il va pas raconter sa vie on n'a
peut-être pas envie de raconter même à
un avocat parce que ça n'avait rien à
voir quand on s'est rencontrés que j'ai
fait de la prison etc il a peut-être pas
envie de raconter ça il a envie de
tourner la page parce autre chose il a
fait des grosses bêtises il a été
condamné il a payé il a purgé maintenant
allez on lui souhaite bon vent dans sa
maison qui fait des enfants qui trouve
un travail c'est beau et ça va être
compliqué de des barbecues et voilà est
7e est-ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut lui
reprocher c'est ce que ce que mathieu a
dit ce qu'il n'a pas dit en fait et
stores a eu lui a alors dit moi je moi
genre à lui dire voilà mille dinars a
juste dit à la presse tu t'es servi de
la presse nous a pas dit la vérité tu me
dis pas que tu sortes chez le notaire
sans clé tu nous dis tu viens avec ta
fiancée pour qu'on ait un peu pitié toi
la charité c'est pas bien ce que vous
êtes en train de lui faire moi je que je
dis maintenant pourquoi mettre le casier
judiciaire ça sert strictement à rien il
a été chez le notaire tout ça ça a été
fait devant la loi française il a signé
sa femme elle a pris un crédit de 140000
euros ils vont le rembourser le crédit
donc maintenant si c'est pour sortir des
trucs sans arrêt comme ça moi je trouve
que ça sert à rien c'est bête il a fait
un coup à la il a fait une maison à 140
milles vous dit rien dedans mais non
quand on rentre dans une maison de façon
il n'y a rien dedans un que le terrain
déjà il a fait une bonne affaire la
maison je pense pas qu'il va faire cent
mille euros d'impôts de 100 mille euros
de travaux je pense pas enfin moi je
suis content moi je suis content parce
que voici maintenant comme a dit
delphine si ça peut servir pour l'escwa
pour les autres qui squattent faut
changer cette loi il a montré qu'en 48
heures on peut changer la loi raymond
moi je suis pas content je suis au lait
et pour moi laurent je vous le dit les
yeux dans les yeux pour moi vous êtes
coupable je t'aimais bien tu veux que me
tu veux que bombarder un messi encore là
c'est fini on l'a réglé le problème ça y
est un nom maintenant je trouve qu'il
est pas
raison est ce qu'il faut
mais je vous le dit les yeux dans les
yeux là à chaque fois vous venez parce
que vous êtes obligés de venir non il
faut marcher ne touchez pas obligé de
l'intérieur tout le monde dit mme aigner
dans un essai moi juste finir parce que
vous subissez parce qu'à chaque fois il
ya de nouvelles révélations à venir et
après il ya quoi bein oui mais c'est pas
si simple rien vu rien je crois qu'on a
on a fait tous ces pauvres laurent après
ses abats l'euro avait un casier après
le rock et la prison est dans la force
on a le doute sur la pompe atteindra
prison mais si cyril mais on a bien sûr
le droit étranger je sais pas ce que je
dis ça c'est insupportable
nouvelles et les dangers de la route
surtout et de réunifier la prière en
doutes sur la transaction mais le doute
surtout laurent goumarre les lots de ces
biens des gens comme lui qui serait
mieux d'avoir le doute
des gens c'est avec des gens comme ça
que tu as ta pas de deuxième chance et
trouve lui valent avant la maison ça
trouve il va trouver un poste en
permanence trois associations qui va la
transaction il a fait ces malins poser
une question on a des victimes ou
coupables à temps mes origines son parti
lors en tout cas bon haye et maintenant
il y aura plus de dents brouille donc ça
y est c'est parti c'est fait d'accord m
toledano va vous suivre
vous avez une petite chance mais je
crois qu'on sera tous les jours j'adore
les barbecues donc voici un motivé
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous êtes
heureux ça va ça se passe bien sûr moi
je suis soulagé on va essayer de passer
à autre chose je suis venu éteindre un
peu un peu le feu et puis on se serait
bien qu'on passe à autre chose
merci et loi soit modifiée et que les
lois sont modifiées que les lois soient
modifiées à même à des sommes tous des
lices être qu'à bessou que les lois
soient votées